[Music]
it's tuesday's pft ot the extra show
that we do to jam in all the things we
couldn't get to during our allotted time
on nbcsn and nbc sports radio and chris
i want to start with some comments from
bruce irvin the former first round pick
of the seattle seahawks who won a super
bowl there comparing his new team's
defensive line to the seattle seahawks
defensive line of that super bowl year
primarily by virtue of the depth the
ability to have that eight man rotation
and bring guys in and out now look that
may be a stretch because that seattle
seahawks defense was special at all
levels are you seeing anything from that
carolina front four when you factor in
the ability to rotate in backups that
makes you think this could be a special
group well i'm glad he qualified depth
because that's that is the thing that
jumps out to me more than anything i
mean i think that's what he's speaking
to you know the talent level of course
with this carolina panthers d-line it's
good but i'm certainly not going to put
it into the class right of that seattle
seahawks team where you know yes some of
the backups number five six seven and
eight on the seattle defensive line you
know in that 2013 season would have been
starters for for most teams in football
that's how special that was but when you
break it down mike and you get into it
okay and you talk about brian burns the
pass rusher with mario addison okay and
they got guys that could come off the
bench there and supplant them but to me
is the waves of big people in the middle
of their defense that's amazing you know
when you get into vernon butler who was
a first round pick and the woodrow
hamilton who plays and kyle love and oh
gerald mccoy and oh dante dante po and
then you go oh gosh i forgot kawan
short's there and then you go destiny
vallejo who's been helping the eagles
the last two years and you just go wow
okay yes so it might not be the sexiest
names the most household names you know
big time statistical people but it's a
lot of big people that jump out to me
and a lot of quality players not
necessarily maybe seattle star players
all the more reason to think the
panthers could be a sneaky good team
this year yeah hinging on whether and to
what extent quarterback cam newton can
stay healthy and before he stays healthy
he has to fully get healthy in the
aftermath of that offseason shoulder
surgery teddy bridgewater has had a hard
time getting healthy in the aftermath of
the torn acl he suffered three years ago
in a practice just a few days before the
start of the regular season he decided
to stay with the saints this year after
his one-year contract expired the saints
had given up a third round pick to get
him from the jets after he signed a
contract in new york and bridgewater
explains that he stayed in new orleans
because he wants to grow as a player he
didn't have a lot of options chris the
dolphins wanted him and if he decided
miami you know what happened josh rosen
shows up the the second day of the draft
so at least teddy bridgewater has an
opportunity to maybe get to the point
where he has a chance to replace drew
brees whenever brees retires and it
could be a combination of bridgewater
and taysom hill in new orleans with
taysom hill still coming out from time
to time and teddy bridgewater running
the offense and and and who knows look i
don't know that his knee is ever going
to be what it was before it was
uh gruesomely torn right in that
incident nearly three years ago but i i
kind of like the idea that bridgewater's
just kind of out there operating under
the radar screen with the possibility
that someday we're going to be reminded
that you know he was on track to being a
decent quarterback yeah no no question i
mean i honestly think it was a smart
move by teddy bridgewater unless there
was just some you know can't lose type
of situation out there where oh you're
going to be the starter and you're the
guy and you don't have to worry about us
drafting or you know trading for josh
rosen
then this was the right move and that
situation did not exist so i think he
made the right decision one you know hey
you're in a great spot you're learning
from a great coach and you're improving
your game uh you're getting back to
where you might you know might have been
before the knee injury or c or at least
getting as close as you possibly can get
in another situation like this where
you're not going to be expected to play
and every the burden of that's going to
be on you right away and the biggest
thing to me mike is you know hey man if
drew brees let's just say it gets a high
ankle sprain or hurts his shoulder and
you're the backup quarterback of a team
man this is the team to be a good backup
quarterback for we've seen you know
josh mccown or luke mccown when he used
to come in for drew brees he used to put
up phenomenal numbers and because of the
offense and the team they have around
him if bridgewater got two or three
games to show what he's got and showed
some success and oh wow he can still
play at a high level it's only going to
set him up for the future to get
everything he wants and get that you
know the market clamoring for him again
to be a starting quarterback somewhere
states got a playoff win in january over
the philadelphia eagles and that's when
we last saw fletcher cox on a football
field the eagles defensive lineman has
not participated in anything since then
he had a foot injury had surgery he
recently told wapt in jackson
mississippi that he anticipates being
ready for training camp he said
everything is going good i'm happy about
that taking it day by day the goal is to
be ready for camp doctors got a schedule
i'm following what they're doing
everything is going good so far the
eagles need this guy they're a different
defense when he's not on the field and
yes they've added malik jackson they
kept timmy jernigan but they need
fletcher cox to be healthy or it's going
to be a lot harder for the for the
eagles to stop people chris he's
phenomenal football player i mean
mike you know we talk about him a lot
and i know maybe a lot of it's even off
air but this is a guy that is in the
conversation for one of the five best
defensive players in football i mean
he's in the conversation for the best
defense alignment in football not named
aaron donald and i'll say this i don't
think the gap between him and aaron
donald is as big as maybe people might
perceive it to be because some of what
fletcher cox does does not go on the
stat sheet when he just you know makes a
mosh pit in the middle of the defensive
line and holds a double team or a triple
team and just stands there and doesn't
get moved that doesn't go on the statute
those are things that he's better at
than aaron donald at but nobody's ever
gonna always be able to you know kind of
quantify it with the stats and
everything like that but i'm with you
mike it's a big deal this is the this is
the big stud on that eagles defense and
they need him you know to be playing
certainly because the style of play and
what they ask him to do is special and
it certainly helps their defense
yeah that's absolutely true and uh i've
got high hopes for the eagles this year
um but uh that that that hinges on the
presumption that fletcher cox is going
to be good to go when the regular season
begins and he's hopeful that he'll be
ready for
training camp all right there's been
plenty of talk over the past couple of
weeks about the nfl's intent to make
pass interference subject to replay
review we spent some time last week
talking about a play from the chargers
chiefs week 15 game that al river on the
nfl senior vp of officiating has
disclosed would have resulted in a
ruling on the field of defensive pass
interference becoming offsetting fouls
because replay review would have shown
that mike williams the chargers receiver
pushed off to gain separation on a play
that ultimately didn't result in a
reception so it would have been a
do-over and there may be more plays like
that where the end result is they'll
just say offsetting fouls and we'll do
it all again but there's another play
that rich eisen mentioned in his monday
guest appearance at football morning in
america that got my attention chris the
super bowl 53 play right before the
interception that sealed the game when
jared goff went right back to the
brandon cook's well and got picked off
by stefan gilmour one play before that
there was early contact from gilmore on
cooks as he was trying to catch what
would have been a touchdown pass
and al riverron believes that that's a
play that would have been overturned by
replay review and i'm struggling with
this and we've posted a link to the
video you can find it very easily on
google otherwise
the standard is clear and obvious
evidence of an error and including
within that clear and obvious evidence
that the player was significantly
hindered by that early contact
and chris i'm struggling to see clear
and obvious evidence that there is a
significant hindrance of brandon cooks
because even though stefan gilmore
grabbed his arm he cooks rips his arm up
and has both hands in position to catch
the pass and only drops it because duron
harmon was closing in with a big hit the
the the contact from gilmore it's here's
the thing yeah you could have an
argument that it did affect him oh look
it affected him look his arm moved more
slowly or whatever you can't say it's
clear and obvious that the contact from
gilmore significantly hindered brandon
cooks and that takes what happened in
the rams saints game and throws it into
an entirely new environment of potential
calls are going to be overturned that i
don't think the nfl ever intended and
it's going to be a mess if that kind of
thing gets reviewed and reversed in the
2019 season yeah mike i mean this is the
problem this is what where this is the
can of worms we're opening up i mean
again this is why uh if you remember not
long after that game and and the ram
saints and all that you know i know i
clamored i think big cat was even on the
show with me one day where i just said
don't change any of the rules everything
is fine it was a once in a 50-year
mistake it stunk they messed up that's
all there is to it now here we go and i
just i i am hoping for the best this
year but i i see it as past interference
but i can understand how others don't
and i think this is the same argument
we're going to get into a little bit
it's still going in to human error and
how the human sees it as past
interference or not past interference or
clear and obvious or not clear and
obvious and uh that's where it's really
dicey here and i i just i gotta see how
this plays out i'm not necessarily in
favor of any of this at this point and
you know what and here's the thing i got
two points first
all i wanted was a fail safe all i
wanted was break glass in the event of
emergency i wanted to have a mechanism
in place to change that horribly bad
outcome i don't want a mechanism in
place that's going to second-guess every
past interference call and non-call
secondly what this is going to become is
this vague crap shoot roll of the dice
that fans who don't understand all the
nuances are going to think oh hey maybe
there's a chance they're going to press
the button maybe there's a chance
they're going to overturn this i don't
know what i'm seeing i don't know what
i'm looking at but you know what
sometimes they have replay review of
these plays and they throw a pass
interference flag sometimes they pick it
up sometimes they call off setting fouls
i'm just going to sit back and hope for
the best without really appreciating
that this was put in place ideally to
eliminate egregious errors right and
here's the problem if al riveron thinks
that what happened in the chiefs
chargers game is in the same category as
ram saints if he thinks what happened in
super bowl 53 is in the same category as
ram saints this is going to be a mess
and this is where
i'm trying to choose my words carefully
yeah this is where the nfl needs to go
to al river on and say ah that's not the
way it is and if you're not going to be
able to implement this rule as we see
fit we need to find somebody else who
will period and i know that may sound
harsh i'm not saying fire out river on
i'm saying maybe find somebody else who
is going to be in position to handle
those calls because he's going to
micromanage something that is supposed
to be there only in the event that the
house is on fire ram saints the house
was on fire these other place the house
ain't on fire chris right mike i'm i'm
with you and you know you're only
opening it up for all the fixes in the
conspiracies oh the nfl wants this team
in the super bowl and not that team i
mean to me that's where this whole thing
seems to be going let alone i again
we've talked about this a million times
over the last month i'm worried about
the game being bogged down by this and i
have to see the execution of it but mike
i mean you made all the good points i
don't think i have anything else to say
one last topic for today and people will
say well this isn't about pro football
well it is because the nfl is part and
parcel of the problem here with that
artificial barrier that has been erected
to keep college football players in
college for three years after they
graduate from high school california is
working on a bill that would allow
student athletes to gain revenue from
their names images and likenesses no pay
from the schools no money off of the
ncaa's ledger this is players using
their names images and likenesses for
their benefit and the ncaa is squeezing
california a letter from ncaa president
mark emmert
written in a very diplomatic way but
basically threatens california if you do
this your schools aren't going to be
eligible for national championships
chris i think this is bogus it's one
thing to find a way to not pay players
it's another thing to continue to refuse
them the opportunity to make the same
kind of money that olympic athletes can
now make while still retaining amateur
status it's wrong it's immoral it's
greedy and it's overdue for this change
to happen yeah i mean a hundred percent
the ncaa i mean they're not one to be
able to talk about moral integrity or
doing any of that anyways i mean all the
people who got their hands out as far as
you know all you know cash for bowl
games and all of that stuff i mean it's
just as anybody i talk to it's a dirty
weird business as house all goes down
between the ncaa and the bowl
affiliations and everything like that a
lot of money exchanging hands under the
tables it's okay when they're doing it
but damn deion sanders you can't take
dez bryant out for lunch that's a crazy
you broke a raw whoa that's great you
know that i mean that's where we're
going to but yet you know random
committee guy for the fiesta bowl he can
go under and put his hand underneath the
table and take a few thousand dollars
for himself because he brought a guy to
cocktail hour and they had a good
conversation oh okay great yeah it
doesn't seem right seems hypocritical uh
there certainly needs to be more that
goes to the players i know there's a lot
of good things and certainly yes you
have scholarships and all that but
you're right i mean this is a can't lose
billion dollar industry of college
football jersey sales likenesses
apparels all of those things and
very small fraction goes to the players
and a lot of which what everybody thinks
is like oh they're division one
scholarship athletes you know they're
sitting in back in their dorm room
that's you know better than any other
dorm room and football and you know they
got their own lunch and cafeteria no
it's not like that it's not and a lot of
the guys
yeah go ahead a lot of guys have a hard
time having extra meals during the day
yeah
they they get value for what they do but
it's not fair value yes for what they
bring to the table right and this is a
way to allow the players to get some
semblance of fair value for what they do
now you know a lot of the things you
suggested we're not making any specific
accusations against any specific people
about wrongdoing committed by anyone
affiliated with any ncaa institution i'm
just doing that chris so you don't get
sued thank you but but and you i assume
you agree with everything i just said
any specific organizations i agree there
we go i'm just just trying to be clear
counselor uh but uh
the the point is this there's an
imbalance a gross imbalance and and i
think the people who just want to enjoy
their college sports without being
burdened by the ethical dilemma of
asking yourself is it right to sit there
and enjoy that college football game
when you know deep down that these kids
are getting screwed and if in california
they're trying to be leaders when it
comes to finding a way to allow the
imbalance to be rectified and the ncaa
is trying to squat on their heads over
it that that's amazing to me there's got
to be a way there's got to be a way to
to let these kids get something more for
what they do and if you can do it
without taking any of the money away
that's coming through the coffers anyway
then then why should it be a problem so
anyway that's all we need to say about
it it's wrong it needs a change and i
don't know that it ever will that's it
for today's pft ot a new edition of
chris sims unbuttoned is coming up later
today is uh phil making your appearance
today the big effort will be on there
today i don't know we've changed around
the time of the podcast so i can't
guarantee it right now so i'm not a
hundred percent sure i'm only like
eighty percent sure
the big effort is not real flexible when
it comes to changing his times no yeah
no he's got a strict schedule a strict
schedule of things and who knows what
he's got to do
all right well we'll check that out
later today we'll see everybody tomorrow
three more days until we begin our
hiatus once once chris gets his four
weeks off he may never come back so who
knows this may be his last three days
ever either way we'll be back on
wednesday everybody have a great day
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports